what does it take to run in your
network fast like how hard is that
compilation it's really hard
um so we just skipped you said like it's
amazing that that's a thing
but yeah how hard is that of a thing
it's hard and i i would say that
not all of the systems are really great
including the ones i helped build
so there's a lot of work left to be done
there is it the compiler nerds working
on that or is it
a whole new group of people well it's a
full stack problem including compiler
people um including apis so like keras
and
the the the module api and pytorch and
jacks and there's a bunch of people
pushing on all the different parts of
these things because
when you look at it as it's both how do
i express the computation
do i stack up layers well cool like
setting up a
linear sequence of layers is great for
the simple case but how do i do the hard
case
how do i do reinforcement learning well
now i need to integrate my application
logic in this
right then it's you know the next level
down of how do you represent that
for the run time how do you get hardware
abstraction
and then you get to the next level down
saying like forget about abstraction how
do i get the peak performance out of my
tpu
or my iphone accelerator or whatever
right and all these different things and
how
and so this is a layered problem with a
lot of really interesting uh
design and work going on in the space
and a lot of really smart people working
on it
machine learning is a very well funded
area of investment right now
and so there's a lot of progress being
made so how much innovation is there on
the
lower level so closer to the to the asic
so redesigning the hardware or
redesigning concurrently compilers with
that hardware
is that like if you were to predict the
biggest
uh you know the equivalent of moore's
law improvements
in the inference and the training of
neural networks
sure and just all of that where is that
going to come from you think sure you
get scalability you have different
things and so you get
um you know jim keller shrinking process
technology you get three nanometer
instead of five or seven or 10 or
28 or whatever um and so that that
marches forward that provides
improvements
you get uh architectural level
performance and so the
you know a tpu with a matrix multiply
unit and a systolic array is much more
efficient than
having a scalar core doing multiplies
and adds and things like that
you then get
system level improvements so how you
talk to memory how you talk
across a cluster of machines how you
scale out how you
have fast interconnects between machines
you then get system level
programming models so now you have all
this hardware how to utilize it
you then have algorithmic breakthroughs
where you say hey wow cool
instead of training in uh you know resin
at 50 and
uh a week i'm now training it in you
know 25 seconds
yeah and now it's a combination it's a
combination of uh you know
new new optimizers and new new new just
training regimens and different
different approaches to train and
and all these things come together to
push the world forward
that was a a beautiful exposition
but if you were to uh forced to bet all
your money and one of these
would you why do we have to yes
unfortunately we have people working on
all this it's an exciting time right
so i mean you know openly i did this
little
paper showing the algorithmic
improvement you can get has been you
know improving exponentially
i haven't quite seen the same kind of
analysis
on other layers of stackd i'm sure it's
also
improving significantly i just it's a
it's a nice intuition builder
i mean there's a reason why moore's law
that's the beauty of moore's law is
somebody writes a paper
that makes a ridiculous prediction yeah
and it you know becomes reality
in a sense there's there's something
about these narratives when you uh
uh when chris latina on a silly little
podcast makes
uh bets all his money on a particular
thing somehow
it can have a ripple effect of actually
becoming real that's an interesting
aspect of it because like it might have
been
you know we focus with moore's law most
of the computing industry
really really focused on the hardware
i mean software innovation i don't know
how much software innovation there was
in terms of what intel giveth bill takes
away
yeah i mean compiler has improved
significantly also
well not not really so actually i mean
so i'm joking about how uh
software's gotten slower pretty much as
fast as harvard got
better yeah at least through the 90s um
there's another joke
another law in compilers which is called
uh i think it's called probsteen's law
which is
uh compilers double the performance of
any given code every 18 years
so they move slowly yeah well so well
yeah it's exponential also yeah but
you're making progress but but there
again it's not about
um the power of compilers is not just
about
how do you make the same thing go faster
it's how do you unlock the new hardware
a new chip came out how do you utilize
it you say oh the programming model how
do we make people more productive
how do we how do we like have better
error messages
even such mundane things like how do i
generate
a very specific error message about your
code actually makes people happy
because then they know how to fix it
right and it comes back to how do you
help people get their job done
yeah and yeah and then in this world of
exponentially
increasing smart toasters how do you uh
expand computing to uh to all these
kinds of devices
you